oh hey guys Ryan right over here I just
notice you there I'm Jerry so today
we're gonna check out two movie clips
for one of the most anticipated films of
the year Avengers age of Ultron first
movie clip called we're the Avengers
yes I'm aware there's the warm-up clip
we all know which clip you really want
to watch and this is just to whet your
palate yeah yeah what your [ __ ] let's
do this get some joss whedon this could
have been avoided if you hadn't played
something you don't understand I'm sorry
it's funny it's cool if you don't get
one can you tell me maybe this might not
be the time really that's it
you just roll over show your belly every
time somebody snarls only when I've
created a murder bot we didn't we
weren't even close when we close to an
interface well you did something right
and you did it right here
The Avengers were supposed to be
different than she anything you remember
when I carried a nuclear wormhole never
come save New York you never heard that
or call that hostile alien army can
charging through a hole in space we're
seeing the freeing her feet below it
with you ventures we can bust arms
dealers on the live long David there
that's I've seen
how are we guys planning on being
together
cap cool clip is a cool clip I'm excited
I'm excited she a little excited to be
like yeah alright when I do appreciate
and this is gonna sound really nerdy but
like I do appreciate that for every like
big action clip they also release a
talkie clip that's something you really
do want from the Avengers is interaction
well and from Joss Whedon - somebody
said that about the first Avengers is
like finally it's a superhero movie
where the talk scenes are just as
exciting as the action see yeah yeah
because it's it's that rare action movie
where you care to really watch
interaction because it's more than just
I want to see some cool fight scenes you
want to see these guys like talk to each
other it's like when you first saw
Pacino and De Niro in heat
let's hope Avengers doesn't become
Righteous Kill alright clip number two
here we go
Hulk Buster versus Hulk I played The
Hulk and reactors Assemble video oh hey
I'm trying to do more faces for you so
you could use it
alright here we go
all right everybody stand down
you listen me that little witch is
messing with your mind you're stronger
than her you're smarter than her you're
Bruce Banner right don't mention puny
banner
okay
[ __ ]
whoa
ouch sweet in the back dick move banner
now
ah
all right it's everything we want change
my pants
yeah it's everything we want that was
pretty [ __ ] sweet it's cool that
Scarlet Witch is [ __ ] with his mind
cuz it gives us the moment that we want
which is Hulkbuster bursting Hulk how
else can you make that happen unless
Hulk's losing the [ __ ] in the wrong way
I love it I do [ __ ] love excited
that's that cool action sequence where
you're like you like both characters you
care about both characters [ __ ]
mayhem is going oh yeah what I'm happy
to see like some Hulk focus I've been
watching all the Avengers movies the MCU
all over again The Incredible Hulk is
like one of the weaker ones I've been
problematic in terms of movies
totally but I did like the last fight
scene of The Incredible Hulk with a bomb
abomination okay these two clips for the
show us interaction it's still good it
also keeps that spirit of you know these
people don't necessarily belong in the
same room and they're still trying to
make it work it's your favorite
dysfunctional family and in the Iron Man
movies he's very much about being solo
you know and it's cool to see Iron Man
kind of taking a leadership role yeah
that's what we got from these two clips
is like he's the one who's like Bruce
dude yeah and then in the clip with the
Avengers like hey I know I [ __ ] up but
were the Avengers yeah we're gonna solve
this yeah and then they all walk away
he's like what I was cool to see ya you
got Rhodey in there yeah yeah yeah Taye
Diggs he's really good or wasn't she
don't happen to you okay yeah the fight
sequence did remind me of the last fight
scene in The Incredible Hulk because in
there there's got to big giant exactly
fighting exactly and you know you get an
equal opponent to the Hulk as opposed to
the Avengers really like Hulk is kind of
like a secret weapon in a way yeah
because like everyone's a lot smaller
and weaker yeah like he takes low key at
one point in just fascism but what he
lacks in strategy he makes up for in the
ability to
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah exactly so you got a real
like [ __ ] mop moment and most the
time when I watch movies like this I'm
like oh god this is where all the money
went to was to create some crazy
explosions and then I'm watching this
and I'm like but it's [ __ ] cool
because these are two characters that we
care about that's what I liked about the
Incredible Hulk fight was that we knew
these characters yeah and it's backed up
with awesome destruction and you know
what and now it's it's it's a cool cuz
I've got a different reason to be
fighting each other now cuz in the first
one day I was like everyone was fighting
each other because nobody got a lot get
along and this time it's like Oh
someone's [ __ ] with you like I don't
want to hurt you but this has to be
under control yeah exactly
rating time rating time definitely going
to my Mad Max I got my 9:30 a.m. tickets
already can't wait go wake up tired
[ __ ] watch this [ __ ] is gonna happen
is my impression of me in the future
[ __ ] I shouldn't have done this and then
wherever the movie starts and then the
movie ends on the car ride home and then
[ __ ] look what I do what I do oh god no
no no no oh I'm so sorry ma'am Oh dump
in the trunk of litter in there o j--
and then drive to cliff you know put the
card we have knock out Latrell watch out
for the vlog where I imagine it hides
body yeah yeah if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects right jerry has a playlist
on this channel check it out reasons -
jerr-bear you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where were
whatever some joke
Vickey barranco hey female subscriber
oh yeah rocking the short haircut yeah I
like the John Connor look you got going
on it's really cool John Connor doesn't
have like the patent on short haircuts
oh yeah ever for a long I know you
that's when I think of John Connor
I don't think of curly hair Jason Clarke
Vicki barranco there's a prophecy that
one day there will be a Supreme
reactions channel that we'll be able to
pierce the barriers of space and time
and bring everyone the best reactions
ever seen before and Ryan I think your
channel is the one oh I'm Ray's dude
your friend looks rocky oh damn far from
like Jesus yeah but a little less holy
thank you that's really sweet of you
it's I'm glad to know that the woman on
this channel are you know seeing me in a
big way
you hear this Tyrone this lady thinks
I'm gonna be the one so back off Tyrone
hey you need to run on your side I don't
need time us our side
Tyrone needs me oh I'm having experience
with Tyrone right oh this is my
impression of me armwrestling with
Tyrone let's do this [ __ ] oh it's
exactly our words Oh what if I do it
what have I done
you know ty Ron's probably jealous of
this Vicki he's probably sitting in his
kitchen right now going mad Vicki yo ass
be pissing me off I don't like you I
don't call woman [ __ ] but if I did I
would call you one Tyrone laughs he's
like sometimes he cracks up he's like oh
[ __ ]